OK.
Let's get into audience questions for the
week, a lot of very similar, it's clear what
the audience is thinking about and I understand
why.
First question is, David, what do we do if
Donald Trump refuses to accept election results?
So there's two different ways that accept
can be interpreted.
He refuses to accept them and that he claims
it was rigged, but he's still leaving or he
refuses to accept it and that he's going to
try to stay in the White House.
Now, I want to again restate, most likely
we don't have to do anything because Donald
Trump, if he loses in November, come January
21st, will simply not be the president.
He's just not the president anymore.
Now, for me, the biggest concern is trump
rigging the election and winning that.
I think that's a bigger concern than him not
accepting the results.
But let's play it out.
We see Trump undermined democracy.
He jokes about staying in power a long time.
He says to Chris Wallace on Sunday, this past
Sunday, he's not yet ready to commit to accepting
the results.
So now there are articles being published
about what what we would have to do if that
was the case.
And most of them say, well, we would have
to mobilize.
Listen, you and I aren't removing Donald Trump.
It's ultimately going to depend on the systems
that we have.
So from a practical standpoint, the most likely
scenario is Trump is going to leave because
on January 21st, he would not be president
anymore.
If he loses the November election and there
would be a new president and at that point
he would be trespassing in the Oval Office
and he would be escorted out.
But where I believe our efforts are better
spent because we ultimately can't control
that.
And I do trust that he will will be removed
if he physically tried to stay.
What we can do is it's only July, so we're
better off doing what we can do to prevent
vote rigging, making sure people aren't dropped
from voter rolls and fighting that in court
as has been done, expanding absentee ballot
access.
I just filled out my absentee ballot application
this week and planned to vote by by mail,
all of that stuff, because with all of these
things and this is going to come up again
later in the segment, prevention is cheaper
than the cure.
If Trump tries to stay in office, I really
don't know how he gets away with it.
He won't be president anymore.
Somebody else will be smoke sworn in and eventually
he's going to be removed and he's not going
to be.
The president made that naive.
Right.
I mean, it's like are there people listening
who really think that that's naive, that even
something like that, like if Biden wins and
he shows up ready for work with his lunchbox
and everything and trumps there and he says,
I'm not leaving, that that's going to be allowed
to happen.
I don't believe that that's going to be allowed
If you believe I'm wrong, I want to hear what
the path would be.
And I understand the fear, which is Trump
has flouted every norm.
He's, you know, constitutional violations,
emoluments, all of this difference of I get
it.
I still don't think that he is going to be
able to stay.
I actually think that Trump the narcissist,
if he loses and this is a big if and we don't
want to put the cart before the horse and
we've got a vote and all of that that I've
been saying, I think if Trump loses, his narcissism
will force him to essentially say, I didn't
want it any way to essentially make it undesirable
when when you have an extreme narcissist and
you take away from them something that they
want, what they typically do is they say,
I didn't really want it or I don't want it
anymore or it's not worth that much anymore.
Let someone else have it.
I'll make more money in real estate, et cetera.
So that is more likely to me if Trump loses
to basically say.
I'm out.
You know, I'm better off going back to real
estate.
Good luck with Joe Biden or whatever, then
trying to stay in power, because that's often
how the narcissist works.
Now, the authoritarian narcissist may try
to stay in power.
And Trump certainly has no shortage of authoritarian
tendencies.
But I believe if he loses, he will leave.
Let's focus on preventing the election from
being rigged against Biden.
There we can do something.